兵馬つパイプメーカーという始めるワールドジャーンランニングライブカメラ甘えの
通りです走れ生放送カメラコレなにかと言いますともうまさにその通りですね車なん
ですけども動かせてで録画できてよく混ぜたいは10卓操作で動かせるみたいですごい
大須5位の遠隔操作ってどれくらいまでいけるのか
30m か思っ
となんか1キロと2キロとかオイラん家から遠く離れた場所の見たかったですね
人が投げてみましょう
ちゃんとカメラになってますねはすごいなあ結構本格的な気がするいやー悪させてー
なー
じゃあちょっとどんなものか調べてみようか
なるほど人はなアタリをダウンロードしましょう愛でましたこちらですね今の
リフレッシュどういうことでこれだけシンプルに追加追ってもいいんだけどね円卓で
コントロールできるのかな
どういうことなんだかで遠隔使ったらどこでもできるのかな接着で行ってみるか
初期化中みたいです
場所の精神を持っている
小森素敵じゃね談義もわかんなかったんだけど間で連れてきたでしょ
あったりなんかまで登録することができましたこちらですねこれがこの車の信号らしい
ですこれで動けば一番いいんですけどね
きたきたきたきたきたきたきたきた上で凄い凄いけど大丈夫
すごいけど大丈夫ん
me
んああああ
これは酷いななんか通信が不安定だなこれは動き来ないの
いや惚れ厳しいをちょっと一応きたいるんですけどさすがすぎるのと困るのとこれね
これで操作できるんですけど全く反応しないです
充電が足りないのもあるかもしれん
あよ
こよまね10おいを
二存分
ただのボイスレコーダー上海というわけでちゃんと充電が少ないみたいなのでに1回壁
で全3巻
はいテレビで充電結構溜まりましたそれでそんな性が良くなっていたなかった話は別だ
ぜそれで動くか
わー動いた
はっはっは
ああ
動かなくなっちゃったよ今の一瞬だけそんなだんだったんゾーン要する動かないんだ
けど今今にもいい感じ
今いい感じだなところ今ちゃんと動いてるよいまちゃんと法律家してるけど
こちょこちょほんとなんかも溶けかけのデジタルモンスターでなってますよ
[音楽]
えええええええええええええっ
おっ
10分
ん
うんっ
使います河合忠海であるといっ
花ますけどっ
まずは何してみようかぞ
使われましたそしてもう一人お客が書きました
[音楽]
where
上の絶景手を伸ばしてナスもとしてとか結ばないで
ん
なにこれを動かしません
なん
[音楽]
バッハ
墓場でどうぞ
ウォンちゃん今日はまた衣
今日のあなたに
i あたりしてみていいかちょっとあるタイアップしてみましょう
work
ネットもせん
ザビ家トップに入りしてみようしまー
オーナーメガネの方が多いんしてみようショップいう
くれほらっっ
4大回転花びら大回転やで羽後すごいなぁ
スゴイねこれを二人とも元気かいなんでいきたい
うるさい
だった
えっ
me
ni
[音楽]
あっはぁ